siempre es bueno ver las distintas
soluciones que se le puede dar a un
problema en particular estos problemas
de razones admiten distintas soluciones
dependiendo de la persona que las
desarrolla en el vídeo que hicimos de
este problema planteamos que en un
principio la razón de manzanas a
naranjas era de 5 a 8 y que cuando
eliminábamos 15 manzanas esa razón se
hacía de 1 a 4 y respondimos a la
pregunta cuántas frutas en total tengo
después de eliminar 15 manzanas
resolvimos el problema y encontramos que
nos quedaban 50 piezas de fruta la
solución encontramos platicando
planteamos nuestras consideraciones de
manera verbal veamos si podemos
resolverlo de una manera más algebraica
así es que hagamos m
el número de manzanas
al inicio las manzanas que teníamos
inicialmente y n el número de naranjas
que no cambia en el número de naranjas
así es que la razón de m&a n la razón de
manzanas naranjas la razón de emea n
esto es igual a me parece que voy a
necesitar más espacio para no amontonar
me en este pequeño pedazo así es que voy
a copiar esto marcamos
copiamos y esto lo vamos a pegar acá
abajo vamos a pegarlo aquí abajo para
tener más espacio listo ahí lo tenemos
quedamos entonces que m es el número de
manzanas al inicio y n es el número de
naranjas y la relación de mn es voy a
escribirla en un color que no haya usado
en blanco que no le usado así es que la
relación de emea en es de 5 a 8 eso es
lo que nos dicen que si en un inicio se
divide el número de manzanas entre el
número de naranjas se establece una
relación de 5 a 8 su razón para ser más
precisos es de 5 a 8 cuando quitamos 15
manzanas nos quedan m menos 15 manzanas
y nos dicen que entonces la razón de
manzanas a naranjas es de 1 a 4 así es
que a menos 15 el número de manzanas que
tenemos cuando quitamos 15 la razón de
eso al número de naranjas resulta
entonces de 1 a 4 veamos si podemos
resolver este sistema tenemos ahora un
sistema de dos ecuaciones
dos incógnitas el número de manzanas m y
el número naranjas n se parecen un poco
las letras podríamos confundirnos pero
no voy a hacerlo con cuidado para que no
nos pase eso déjame volver a escribir
aquí abajo el sistema de ecuaciones la
razón original de manzanas naranjas es
de 5 a 8 y cuando eliminamos 15 manzanas
la nueva razón de manzanas a naranjas es
de 1 a 4 esta es una manera algebraica
de plantear nuestro problema en la
ecuación del lado izquierdo hagamos la
multiplicación cruzada de los
denominadores obtenemos entonces 8 m es
igual a 5 n y si restamos 5 en ambos
lados nos queda del lado izquierdo 8 m
menos 5 n es igual a 0 esta es
simplemente una ecuación lineal con dos
incógnitas que obtenemos en la ecuación
del lado derecho de nueva cuenta hacemos
la multiplicación cruzada de los
denominadores para obtener 4 m menos 60
he hecho la multiplicación de 4 por 15
a uno por n n lo voy a dejar
como 1 n ahora que hacemos vamos a
restar 1 en ambos lados y nos queda 4 m
menos 1 n menos 60 igual a 0 sumamos
ahora 60 ambos lados y obtenemos 4 m
menos 1 n es igual a 60 y aquí se ve
claramente que tenemos un sistema de dos
ecuaciones lineales aquí tenemos una y
aquí tenemos la otra ecuación con dos
incógnitas m y n podría haber usado xy
para designar las variables y así no
confundir ya está n con la m en fin si
tenemos cuidado con eso no hay ningún
problema y cómo resolvemos esto podemos
multiplicar una de las ecuaciones por un
factor adecuado para posteriormente al
sumar o restar las ecuaciones se elimine
una de las variables hagamos eso
multiplicando la primera ecuación por
menos 2 obtenemos menos 8 m más
n es igual a menos 120 esta ecuación la
obtuvimos al multiplicar la ecuación de
arriba por menos 2 sumemos ahora la
ecuación que tenemos aquí es decir vamos
a sumar 8 m menos 5 n que es igual a 0
hacemos la suma menos 8 m 8 m es igual a
0 2 n menos 5 n resulta en menos 13 n lo
cual es igual a menos 120 esto equivale
a n igual dividiendo entre menos 3 ambos
lados de la ecuación se obtiene que n
igual a 40 n igual a 40 ese es el número
de naranjas naranjas igual a 40 es un
valor que no cambia es el mismo al
inicio y al final en igual a 40 ahora
para encontrar el número de manzanas
podemos recurrir a cualquiera de estas
ecuaciones esta es la que se ve más
simple 8 m es igual a 5 n 8 por m es
igual a 5 por el número de naranjas 5
por n es decir 5 por 40
5 x 48 x es igual a 200
dividiendo entre 8 ambos lados a es
igual a 200 sobre 8 lo cual se
simplifica como 100 sobre 4 para obtener
que n es igual a 25 recordemos lo que es
m y n n es el número de naranjas que
tenemos durante todo el problema m es el
número de manzanas con las que empezamos
esto es al inicio al inicio hemos
encontrado que al inicio teníamos 25
manzanas y 40 naranjas es decir
iniciamos con 40 y 25
65 piezas de fruta 65 frutas y al
eliminar 15 frutas al final teníamos 50
frutas la cual es exactamente la misma
respuesta que obtuvimos cuando hicimos
el problema por primera vez qué bueno
que lo hicimos de dos maneras si deseas
saber el número de manzanas al final al
inicio había 25 manzanas se eliminaron
15 con lo cual quedan 10 manzanas
empezamos con 25 manzanas 40 naranjas 65
frutas y terminamos con 10 manzanas 40
en total 50 frutas en fin espero que te
haya sido útil haber resuelto este
problema de una manera diferente